à main
la vie rama
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
bien que les gens l'ont compris et ceux
qui sont derrière leur poste aussi vous
aimez régaler les gens qui sont derrière
le poste de télévision qui tous vous
regarde tous les soirs et qui vous
aiment et qu'ils ont eu envie de vous
régalez vous maintenant ce soir oui et
ces gens là il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont là ce soir il s'appelle gaëtan loïc
emilie priscilla pauline lucie alex
elodie et salimata avec mohamed le rend
les gens qui sont déjà tout simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de plus quand on a un bon sens
si ce n'est des armes vient d'annuler le
verbaliser poterie c'est pour ça qu'on
dit fier le temps de ces crimes
10 hormis les souris la barre a pris le
temps de te dire tu es là
draghi ont des bras pour la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'attends mon cerveau on a fait ça tous
les soirs on aggrave
[Musique]
mais
a pris le temps de décrire
eudi hobby le sourire barnaby le temps
que tu te dis déjà acquis on aimera pour
la vie
notre avis
à
[Musique]
j'ai grandi car elles reviendront plus
le français a passé vite puis en mai les
ventes plus s'il faisait bien sûr que
jamais
santé
[Applaudissements]
décrire une elodie au mileu souri à bâle
a pris le temps de te dire tu es nara
[Applaudissements]
le décrire
ni rami nasri
la vie jeudi
m
la vague est très bas pour la
madame
[Musique]
non
ben ammar
[Musique]
ouais
soit
[Applaudissements]
voilà
merci merci d'avancé merci aux
chroniqueurs nancy avant d'être chez
nous
[Applaudissements]
tous souhaitent de bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année un joyeux noël je vous aime
traoré n'oubliez pas la télé c'est qu'au
delà
[Musique]